هل ترى الميزانية التي حصلت عليها ثانية من
Granger
Milverton أتت في akashavani إلى Sonali
Gionta حصلت ناهي تيلي على مفتاح مماثل
Venera Manticore Sorta في أعماق
جبال الهيمالايا على بعد حوالي 80 ميلاً
خارج كاتماندو ، تشارك قرية Budong
في تقليد يتحدى الموت
كل في  اسم العسل
[موسيقى]
يا بولي لكنني سأسافر أم لا ،
لقد سرقنا ذلك على قرص العسل الخاص بك ،
لكن شراء هذا العسل الثمين يتطلب
أكثر من مجرد قوة ، يجتمع فريق من
صيادي العسل مرتين في السنة
للتحضير ويقود مادان  العبوة
أخيرًا مجرد قاضٍ في مقاطعة أماريلو
أجيرا زيت نظام وقت اللثة الخاص بك تسمعه
عن الطريقة التي يجب أن تذهب بها ،
فأنت لست وحيدًا حتى في مسرح السينما
هذا الممر العميق في Undine اليوم
، لا تزال العادات القديمة تتبع عن كثب
قبل كل مطاردة يجب أن تزور مادان
القرية  المعلم لتلقي مباركته
بينيرو بوذا من قبل أوه لا ثانية ولكن
مشاهدة بعضنا البعض كنت أسطورة عصر
تيكا ماسالا دابا إلى أرافا لي شري رام
كلية الإجابة في
يوم من الأيام مادان سوف تملأ  أحذية الفتيات
في هذه الأثناء يقود فريقه من
صيادي العسل إلى الغابة
، ويؤمن فريق الضفائر Bree
سلالم الحبال المصنوعة يدويًا ثم يغامرون إلى
جانب الجرف حيث يختبئون خلايا النحل ويصدر
الفريق حرائق دخان في الأسفل
لتشجيع النحل العملاق  لتشتت
مادان ، ينزل نفسه على الحبل
المتدلي على بعد مئات الأقدام من
الأرض ،
يا مويرا وإلقانة يخبران القانون
كثيرًا لأم سيتا شيما ميغارا لي أثناء
مناورة شقرا لإخبار عمار
بتثبيت حراري معين قريب أو عن
القليل الحساس متزوج  أرنب الأم
لإميلي ماهر هو جاما
كيماجوري فريق الليموزين الخاص بي على الرغم من اللسع المستمر
على جلده غير المحمي ، إلا أنه يقطع بهدوء
الخلية لأداء واجبه
وتأمين ذهبه السائل ، الجزيرة
لا يتخيلها كينزي ولكنه عمل رهيب
قليلاً.
ولا
حتى هو جمع الصيادين خلايا النحل
وتعبئتها لإعادتها إلى
القرية حيث يتم الاحتفال بعودتهم الآمنة
يو راميرو جينما يموت  اذهب إلى دينامو
محراب أفيلا وليونيد رام الله الذي يمتلكه
بنشاط ، أحتاج إلى
حامل نقال ، أنت ميلي ، أنت تأتي غرام ullatec dummy
sandy لتضع على روني كالين أفضل
محفظتنا عندك ، يمكن لموري أن
تتحدى حديقة أو آزاد
[موسيقى]